il n'y aura pas de véritable solution au
problème global de sécurité alimentaire
sont réintégrés la production agricole
de l'ukraine ainsi que la production
alimentaire et d'engrais de la russie et
de la biélorussie dans les marchés
mondiaux et cela en dépit de la guerre
c'est une sérieuse mise en garde qui a
été lancée ici parce que la guerre en
ukraine pourrait provoquer une crise
alimentaire sans précédent
l'ukraine et la russie se sont les deux
principaux producteurs mondiaux de blé
de maïs de colza et de tournesol la
question ce soir et ce pont des talons
d'une crise alimentaire mondiale mon
invité nicolas mesli qui est agronome et
qui est aussi journaliste spécialisé
dans les enjeux agroalimentaire bonsoir
monsieur merci bonsoir on s'en rend pas
quoi on quand on parle la guerre en
ukraine on parle des victimes civiles on
parle de la russie des armements mais on
parle du 10/11 l'ukraine qui est avec la
russie un des principaux grenier de la
planète c'est l'ancien grenier de l'urss
l'ukraine et vous jouez vous le voyez un
peu dans l'est quand on voit les soldats
faire des tranchées c'est dans un
gisement de on aperçoit de tchernoziom
c'est parmi les meilleures terres
agricoles la planète donc écouter pour
une anecdote j'étais là en ukraine avant
l'invasion en crimée en 2013 et dans une
entrevue fait à kiev avec le président
des producteurs de grains
d'ukrainiens qui disait que le but de
monsieur poutine c'est de former un
cartel de blé et là vous avez 30 % la
prod2 des exportations mondiales de blé
qui sont à ma qui sont donc ces deux
pays-là son contrôle si on veut juste
dans l'huile de tournesol pensez-y la
60% de l'huile de tournesol des pros qui
est exporté provient de l'ukraine et
l'europe fait fesser frites dans cette
huile la
jsk encore en ce moment même en
situation de guerre
la production agricole en ukraine c'est
une très bonne question j'ai encore un
contact en ukraine avec un journaliste
ukrainien et ce qui me faisait c'est que
à peu près et la ffa ou corrobore ces
chiffres là un tiers à peu près de là la
production soit d'aider l'ukraine
produit environ 100 millions de tonnes
ils s'attendent à produire moins de 60
millions de tonnes pourquoi parceque ils
peuvent pas aller en semences et jeudi à
les chansons mines et les vous le voyez
vous même c'est plus un champ pour
produire des denrées c'est les champs de
bataille donc la crise alimentaire va
pas être seulement de ceux qui se
dessine à l'international s'est pas
seulement à l'international c'est au
sein même de l'ukraine et là vous voyez
je sais pas si vous avez une carte avec
les porcs mais vous voyez que le but de
monsieur poutine c'est exactement on
parle de mario paul jusqu'à odessa tout
ça c'est sous contrôle russe ce que
cherche à faire monsieur poutine en tout
cas vladimir poutine c'est dans le fond
c'est d'étouffer l'économie ukrainienne
pourquoi parce que l'agriculture est un
gros pourcentage du pib produit
intérieur brut et si tu peux pas
exporter tu tu étouffes alors ils sont à
son ils essaient de vers l'europe de
trouver des chemins de fer ou en tout
cas voir comment chaminé ça mais là
j'avais les chiffres je vous dis ça
c'est que les gîtes la turquie
bangladesh et l'iran écoutez 60% de leur
blé provient de l'ukraine et de la
russie alors c'est pour ça qu'il ya sept
monsieur thérèse qui levait la main qui
disait attention et c'est pas la
première fois parce que le pam on a
parlé aussi récemment en faisant on se
sent ligne vers une crise une famine en
réalité est là ce sont des morts dont
des victimes collatérales de ce conflit
parlons de la russie parce que la russie
aussi vous l'avez dit un grand
producteur mais dans son cas ce qui
bloque tout ce sont les sanctions nous
avons nous mêmes est posé on en impose
exactement mais regardez c'est que la
russie va pouvoir exporter à dans
d'autres marchés que leno ça dépend de
quoi vous parlez au niveau du grain on
n'est pas dépendant de la russie mais au
niveau des engrais je vous dirais que
oui écoutez près de la moitié des
engrais qu'on utilise dans l'est du
canada des on appelle ça des engrais
azotés l'urée si vous voulez ça sert
c'est l'élément essentiel pour faire
pousser des plantes près de la moitié de
ces engrais là ces engrais azotés là
proviennent viennent par bateau et
proviennent de la russie exactement le
gouvernement canadien a répliqué envoyer
des amis des sanctions dont
l'interdiction aux bateaux russes de
s'amarrer dans les eaux dans les ports
ou naviguer dans les eaux canadiennes
et ils ont aussi à partir de début mars
instaurer un tarif de 35 % sur les
engrais provenant de ce pays là et de la
biélorussie aussi donc à ce moment-là ça
veut dire que pour les producteurs
agricoles de l'est du canada leurs coûts
de production vont quelque part augmenté
maintenant je vais faire une entrevue
avec un très gros importateurs qui
s'appelle soyaux là qui est une grosse
coopérative au québec et on me disait
que pour le moment on avait réussi à si
vous voulez avoir 75 % des engrais
disponible pour le début de la saison
mme à partir de juillet-août tout ce qui
est tout ce qu'ils voient continue par
après ballet va falloir payer là dessus
alors c'est ça finalement c'est les
coûts qui vont augmenter de beaucoup et
ça finit toujours par se répercuter par
la suite dans la chaîne de production
jusqu'au consommateur nécessairement
quand on parle des réserves du grenier à
la vous reparle du grenier de l'europe
mais le canada aussi les etats-unis
aussi sont de grands producteurs de blé
de grains est ce que ça peut compenser
pour la demande mondiale ça pourrait
compenser que je vous explique julie
pourquoi c'est à dire que le canada ait
produit je vous dirais il produit la
cadillac des blés et on notre blessèrent
a souvent des mélanges pour les
boulangers dans les autres les au pays
on l'a on le mélange avec avec d'autres
les deux moins de qualité alors si on
regarde ça on regarde le canada qui
produit la cadillac des blés on regarde
les états unis qui produit une ford qui
ont regardé on regarde la russie produit
une lada nous on a des marchés très très
spécialisés il faudrait on pourrait
prendre plus d'expansion si vous avez
tout à fait raison c'est à dire que
quelque part avec ce qui se passe dans
le monde aujourd'hui le canada je vous
le rappelle c'est le deuxième plus grand
pays du monde on ne les terres on a
l'eau on se doit quelques passes on se
dit d'être une mini puissance bien
commencé à avoir une véritable stratégie
alimentaire vous montrer en ce moment à
à l'écran des paniers des deux c'est à
dire des sacs dead ios said les
américains on se confond ce qu'on
appelle là sauf diplomatie le canada il
serait temps avec les ressources qu'on a
de nous aussi joué un jeu un rôle
beaucoup plus important qu'on le joue
actuellement merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue qui est aussi une analyse
monsieur mais c'est pas intéressant et
éclairant
merci à vous bonne fin de soirée on va
voir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit